ea spectateurs cher spectatrice nous
sommes des médiatrices médiateur
scientifique
nous souhaitons vous transmettre des
informations en lesquels nous pensons
pouvoir avoir confiance
mercredi dernier l'om est à qualifier la
propagation du coronavirus de pandémie
c'est une situation inédite qui nous
semble justifier notre mobilisation
exceptionnelle en ce moment même de par
le monde des milliers de personnes
infectées par la maladie kobe de 19 sont
en train de se battre pour leur vie en
chine le coronavirus a déjà causé des
milliers de morts
et si sa propagation semble aujourd'hui
maîtrisée cela n'a été qu'au prix de
mesures de confinement très forte dans
le reste du monde et particulièrement en
europe
sa progression continue à un rythme
élevé dans certaines régions parmi les
plus touchées les médecins sont parfois
contraints de choisir quels patients
soignés et quels patients ne recevront
pas les soins adéquat faute de
ressources humaines et matérielles
suffisantes
il semble urgent d'éviter que de tels
dilemmes traumatisant seront également
nombreux autres médecins et famille
certes individuellement vous qui
regardez cette vidéo n'allait
probablement pas mourir du coronavirus
vous n'allez même probablement pas en
souffrir directement
cependant à moins de prendre dès à
présent des mesures drastiques pour
réduire la propagation du virus
vous risquez de le transmettre de proche
en proche à votre insu même si vous ou
vos enfants n'avaient pas de symptômes
il y à un risque que vous soyez infectés
vous risquez de devenir un maillon dans
une chaîne de contamination qui pourrait
toucher de plus large population en
particulier des populations plus
vulnérables que vous or ces populations
auront besoin de soins intensifs et leur
traitement pourrait conduire à une
surcharge des services intérieurs
spitalier ce qui rendrait encore plus
difficile l'accès à des soins adéquats
la bonne nouvelle toutefois c'est que
vous pouvez agir vous pouvez aider à
ralentir efficacement la propagation du
coronavirus pour cela il vous suffit de
suivre les recommandations des services
de santé et des gouvernements
même si celle-ci vous paraissent très
contraignantes ou disproportionnée
limitez vos interactions sociales annulé
la soirée
éloignez vous des foules lavez vous
régulièrement les mains avec du savon
ne serrez pas les mêmes les autres et ne
les embrasser pas tous ses dents
de coude ou dans un mouchoir jetable
éviter de toucher les boutons
d'ascenseur les digicodes les rampes les
poignées de porte et tout ce qui est
susceptible d'être manipulés par
beaucoup de gens fréquemment et éviter
de vous toucher le visage si vous
toussez si vous avez de la fièvre si
vous montrer des signes de la maladie
redoublé de précautions pour ne pas
propager le virus restait au maximum
chez vous pour protéger les autres et
renseignez vous sur les dernières
recommandations en vigueur
ne paniquez pas protégez-vous et
protéger les autres
pour endiguer la propagation de ce virus
veillez aussi à mieux vous informer à
son sujet en consultant des sources
fiables et à jour
méfiez-vous en particulier des sources
douteuses car malheureusement dans ce
contexte les fausses informations se
propage elle aussi très vite elles
peuvent freiner dangereusement les
mesures de précaution
notre connaissance du virus et notre
coopération des la situation chaque jour
grâce au travail monumental des
scientifiques et des agences sanitaires
donnez-vous correctement informés nous
vous invitons notamment à consulter les
descriptions de cette vidéo qui liste de
nombreuses ressources de vulgarisation
ainsi que des ressources d'autorité
reconnu enfin vous pouvez contribuer
plus encore en relayant cette vidéo et
en encourageant vos associations vont
entreprise votre toit à eux aussi de
prendre les mesures de prévention
adéquates pour freiner la propagation du
corona virus le coronavirus est un défi
qu'il nous faut relever collectivement
nous comptons sur votre support et votre
aide pour limiter ces dégâts et revenir
aussi vite que possible à une vie plus
sereine
merci